The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Welcome back.
Today is probably our
last lecture about 3SAT,
but this time it's about
planar 3SAT, which we've
sort of alluded to in the past.
And we saw a version
of what you might
call planar 3SAT with planar
CircuitSAT last class.
But planar 3SAT is a very
useful special case of 3SAT.
It is just like
3SAT, but you also
are told that the bipartite
graph, let's say of variables
versus clauses is
a planar graph.
So the idea is you have
some vertices representing
variables.
v for variable here.
And then you separately
have some clauses.
I guess I should really
have more variables.
You have an edge between a
variable and a clause whenever
that clause includes
that variable,
either in positive
or negative form.
So maybe some of
these edges, I'll
draw a red to
indicate, actually,
that's v bar that is
included in this clause.
So this clause is
vi or vj bar or vk.
And so on.
And this graph should be planar,
shouldn't have any crossings.
Something like that would be
a valid input to planar 3SAT.
Question.
AUDIENCE: So if
you're given the fact
that a particular
bipartite graph is planar,
is there a polynomial operation
to find a planar arrangement?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Deciding whether
a graph is planar
and finding a planar embedding
when it is is linear time.
So here I'm just saying it's
given as a planar graph,
but not with an embedding.
So we're going to use the
embeddings in our reduction.
Yeah, good point.
So we do actually
need the ability
to draw these things
without crossings.
Good.
So first thing I'm going to
do is prove that this is hard.
And usually I don't prove
base problems are hard,
but this is a sufficiently
sophisticated base problem.
I mean, we do lots of
reductions from planar 3SAT.
But the proof is
actually from 3SAT,
and I think it's a
representative example of how
to build a crossover in
this kind of setting,
and what kind of
extra properties
you can get out of it.
So here it is.
This is the proof
in a single diagram.
So the notation here is that
the little green circles
are clauses.
And the bigger circles
are the variables.
Purple circles are variables.
So the idea is it in
your initial instance--
so we're going to
reduce from 3SAT.
We're given an
arbitrary 3SAT instance.
So that has a corresponding
bipartite graph.
Variables versus clauses.
Just not planar.
So consider any drawing.
Actually, we'll look at a
specific drawing in a moment.
But it's going to have
some crossings like this.
This is a clause-variable
connection, another one.
They cross here.
We're going to replace that
with this picture, which
is technically not 3SAT, because
there's a four-variable clause
in the center.
But we can fix that.
That's not too hard.
Let me first convince
you-- and this'll
take a little while-- that
this is equivalent to this.
So the ultimate
claim-- so there's
four Greek letters in the
center as extra variables.
The main claim is that
a1 equals a2 equals a.
And b1 equals b2 equals b.
If that's true, then, of
course, this connection
simulates that connection.
And that connection
simulates this connection.
And the claim is as
long as you satisfy
that, you can always set
the stuff in the middle
to be happy.
So those are the only
constraints, basically.
So let's start with
over here and down here.
These little sort of length two
paths-- sorry, so the coloring
is similar to what
I did on the board.
The red are negative
connections,
meaning that clause has not
a and this clause has not a2.
And the blue connections
are positive connections.
So when you have this sort of
alternating four-cycle here,
you can read that
as not a or a2,
which is the same as
saying a implies a2.
And also, a2 implies a.
That means they
have the same value.
a if and only if a2.
Or I'll just write equality
of their truth values.
Same thing here.
So that part is just
to get warmed up.
Now the fun part
is on the inside.
And I think the next
step is to think
about these sort of
triangles in the corner.
If you stare at them
for a little while,
you get these kinds
of constraints.
So let's work through this one.
You'll see there's a certain
symmetry among what the alpha,
beta, gamma, deltas are.
They're going to be all
sort of all patterns of a2
possibly complemented, anded
with b2 possibly complemented.
So these are supposed to be
the four cases of a versus b.
The trick is that some of them
are 2's and some of them are
1's.
So that's what makes it
a little bit annoying.
It would be nice to make
it perfectly symmetric,
but that would, in terms
of these labels-- but that
would destroy planarity.
So this is the planar version.
So let's look at this.
We have, for example,
not alpha or b2.
So alpha implies b2.
Also, alpha implies a2.
So if alpha is true, then
they must both be true.
And conversely, I want
a2 and b2 to imply alpha.
Right.
So if these are both
true, then this guy's
unsatisfied from
those two red clauses.
So alpha must be true.
Good.
So it works in both directions.
You get equality.
It's exactly the same in
each of these four corners,
just the coloring is different.
And you're connected
to a different b.
So here if you reflect, you're
connected to b1 instead of b2.
And there's a complement
here basically
because these two colors
switched from here.
So it's exactly
the same argument,
but you just imagine
flipping the value of b1.
And then reflect over here.
Switch the value of the a's.
Reflect over here, switch
the coloring of the b's.
So that's what's
happening in the corners.
And at this point, I had to
draw a table of all the cases.
Oh, sorry.
This is a little bit about
what happens in the center.
So of course, the center clause
says that at least one of these
is true.
We want exactly one to be
true, because exactly one
of these cases should happen.
But that's a weak constraint.
And then we also
have some constraints
like if alpha is true, then this
is not satisfied from alpha.
And similarly, this.
And therefore,
beta must be false.
So if alpha is true, then
beta and delta are false.
I think that's
actually all you need.
I think these might
not be necessary.
But they make for a
nice symmetric diagram.
And they don't hurt.
So now I drew a table-- there
may be a more direct argument--
of all the possible
settings a2 and b2,
and what you can
derive from that.
And everything except this
part is really easy to derive,
assuming I can remember
what I did last night.
So let's say a2
and b2 are false.
I claim alpha is false,
because we have this equation.
That's easy.
And in general, you can
compute alpha directly,
because it's just a
function of a2 and b2.
It's the end function.
So that's good.
What about beta?
I claim if alpha is false here,
then in this particular case--
well, OK.
Here's one thing we wrote.
Alpha implies not
beta and not gamma.
So in this last row,
if alpha is true,
we know that beta
and gamma are false.
That's good.
We hope also that beta
and delta are false.
We hope also that
gamma is false.
But I don't think we
need that, because if you
look at this equation
on delta, which we know
is 0, that must mean that
one of these two things is 0.
But b2 is true.
Sorry.
I'm going to use true
and 1 interchangeably,
and 0 and false for
whatever reason today.
So this needs to be
0, but this is 1.
So this must be 0, which
means that a1 is 1.
And symmetrically on the top,
this is a symmetric between a
and b.
So up here, you
know that a2 is 1.
And therefore, b1 bar must be 0.
So b1 must be 1.
So we transfer the information.
And the only other thing
to check in all these cases
is that actually
everything is satisfied.
But that's sort of boring.
I want to do the
other direction, which
is that you are
forced to communicate
the copies of a and
the copies of b.
So that was the last row.
I think the first
row should also
be easy for a slightly
different reason.
So a2 and b2 are false.
Alpha is false.
Beta is false.
That's as far as
we've gotten so far.
Let's see.
Delta is a1 bar and b2, right?
Right.
Because b2 is false, we
know that delta is false.
So it doesn't matter what a1 is.
So it's sort of the
reverse direction.
And similarly, we
should be able to-- oh,
because from this, we know
at least one of them is true,
at least one of the
Greek letters is true,
then we've got three down.
So it must be
gamma that is true.
And once you know
gamma is true, you
know exactly what a1 and b1 are.
So that's another good case.
These are slightly
more annoying,
at least as far as I could see.
Maybe there's a
cleaner argument.
So let's say they're
symmetric, though.
So let's do the second row.
So a2 is 0.
b2 is 0.
I think just like
this argument, we
get that beta is 0,
because beta involves a2.
We know a2 is 0, so beta
equals 0, just like this case,
actually.
OK.
So that's good for that.
I think it's harder
to figure out delta.
Or here's one way to argue it.
Suppose that gamma were 1.
It should be 0, because
gamma's supposed to be only 1
in this situation.
If it's 1, then I claim that
alpha 1 and beta 1 must be 0.
That's from this equation.
And then we should
get a contradiction.
Help me find the contradiction.
AUDIENCE: Delta becomes 1.
PROFESSOR: Delta becomes 1.
AUDIENCE: And then the clause
between gamma and delta is--
PROFESSOR: And then
this is unhappy.
Good.
OK.
So we do need a couple other
constraints like this one.
Cool.
So that's the idea.
Therefore, gamma is 0.
And then by that,
delta must be 1.
And then we're happy again.
OK?
So that's the idea
in a nutshell.
There's maybe other
ways to see it.
And this is an old proof
by Lichtenstein in 1982.
It's a cool paper.
It has a lot of results in it.
We'll be covering a
few different results.
But at this point,
we have shown this.
You just apply this
to each crossing.
Eventually you get a
planar bipartite graph
that's satisfiable if and only
if the original is a planar
3SAT is NP-hard.
Question?
So many questions.
AUDIENCE: I guess this
is probably silly.
But [INAUDIBLE]
3SAT, every clause
had to have three variables.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
OK.
Right.
AUDIENCE: Two or four.
PROFESSOR: I cheated
a little bit here.
OK.
Yeah.
Some have two.
So for that, I need to be able
to construct the value false.
And some have four.
The four, I believe
the claim is you
can take a little
clause like this
and convert it into a clause
with another variable.
AUDIENCE: And one of
the two edges connecting
the variables [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Like this?
So the claim is this four-way
clause to the 4SAT clause
is equivalent to these
two 3SAT clauses.
Let's call this new variable x.
So the idea is x is
going to represent
whether the left side satisfies
the clause or the right side
satisfies the clause.
If x is 1, then it
satisfies this for free.
But it doesn't satisfy this
one, so at least one of these
must be satisfied.
On the other hand, if x is 0,
then it satisfies this one.
And so at least one of these
two should be satisfied.
OK?
So that's a reduction from
4SAT to 3SAT, so to speak.
Now, I didn't create
any degree-two clauses,
but I have tons of degree-two
clauses over there.
AUDIENCE: Just use
parallel edges.
PROFESSOR: Just
use parallel edges.
So you could just repeat the
same variable in the clause
multiple times.
That sounds good.
I don't know if there's an easy
way to avoid multiple edges.
I think it's a little tricky.
You can't construct false
in the CircuitSAT sense,
because everything you
build should be satisfiable.
So you have to be
a little careful.
But it might be possible
to pair them up,
because there should be an
even number of those guys.
And so maybe you pair them up
and connect them in some way.
But let's just allow
multiple edges here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In the original
instance of 3SAT,
does it allow two clauses
with two variables?
For getting planar?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I mean, in general, this would
work for any kind of SAT,
any kind of CNF-SAT.
We're not relying on three-ness
at all in this picture.
But it's not going to
split things up, of course.
AUDIENCE: But the
definition of 3SAT
has three distinct
variables in each clause.
PROFESSOR: There are
a couple definitions.
One has exactly
three, but we never, I
think, specify that
they are distinct.
I think that is hard when
they're all distinct.
But I don't know the
reduction offhand.
I think the way we define
it is there's exactly three,
but we didn't say
any uniqueness.
So let's say that.
And then we're still
happy here, because we
can duplicate variables.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why did we include the
a equals a2, and b equals b2?
PROFESSOR: I think it's
for the next slide.
[LAUGHTER]
The next claim is that not only
is that bipartite graph planar,
but it also remains planar if
we connect all the variables
together in a cycle.
So let's say we number
the variables 1 through n.
It doesn't matter
how you number them.
Well, in a certain sense.
You can restrict to
instances of 3SAT
that this cycle plus the
variable clause adjacency graph
is together planar.
OK?
So that's less clear here.
But let me prove it.
This is proved in
the same paper.
So here's a top-level diagram
of what we're trying to do.
So we have clauses on one hand.
Let's put them
all on the y-axis.
We have variables
on the other hand.
These are the original variables
in the original 3SAT instance.
Put them on the x-axis.
Then draw all the connections
in the bipartite graph.
And furthermore, draw this
cycle on the vertices down here.
OK?
And obviously, we
put them in the order
that they appear in the cycle.
Otherwise we're making
our lives harder.
And here is that
crossover gadget.
This is how it's
originally drawn.
In this case, it's already
been expanded in the center
into that picture over there.
This is where I got
that reduction from.
And then there's no
color here, but you'll
notice the curvy line is an
attempt to connect together
all of the variables that
appear in the crossover
gadget in linear order without
introducing any crossings.
So that diagram is still planar
when we add all of those edges.
And so what this says
is that if we-- we're
trying to build a
global cycle that
connects all the variables.
So obviously, we have
this for these variables,
but we need to add
into this cycle
all the variables that appear
in all these crossings.
And so what this says is if
we are coming in either here
or here into a1, we
can follow this path
and then leave either
here or here on a2.
OK?
And because the diagram
is symmetric, also,
if you're coming into
b1, you can end up in b2.
And I'm guessing this
is why we separate b2.
The reason we separated
b2 from b in general
is to basically add
this connection,
so we can separate this
gadget from this gadget.
So just showing that we
can copy and extend things.
It may not be necessary,
but it definitely
matches this diagram.
OK.
So this diagram is
this diagram, but where
every intersection plus a few
extra places, like over here,
we add these little diamonds.
The diamonds
indicate that gadget.
Then sorry there's no
color, but in curved lines
is the attempt to connect
all the variables together
in one single path.
Question.
AUDIENCE: So what are the
extra crossover gadgets
that don't cross anything over?
PROFESSOR: They're just
to do this path thing.
So what are they?
I mean, they are
exactly this gadget,
just there's no
connection on the left.
AUDIENCE: So they're a crossover
of the path on the variables.
Is that right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So instead of going
straight here,
you just put a crossover
gadget in the middle.
You can still go through.
You're copying some
arbitrary information here
to some arbitrary
information here.
So you don't preserve the
number of solutions, let's say.
But who cares?
The reason for that is so
that we can take this path,
connect to this vertex,
and then get out over here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
what I meant by crossing.
PROFESSOR: So that we can
do this kind of loop thing.
So how do we follow the path?
I mean, we basically do
it in scan-line order.
It's like some
printers used to do
this, where they
print back and forth,
left and right, line printers.
So we come in here.
I don't know quite why they draw
it coming in the middle here.
But it's essentially
coming to this vertex.
Then ending on this
vertex on the left side.
Then going into this vertex,
which brings us to here.
Let's say coming on the top.
Doesn't matter.
And then we go to the right
till we get to the end.
Here we add an extra crossover,
so we can basically cross over
this line with our path.
And add another one.
And whenever we visit an
intersection, we can just go.
And then we go to the
next line and so on.
We clear?
Then at the very end, we're
either on the right or left,
depending on parity.
Probably we want
to be on the right.
So if we're on the left, we'll
just add extra crossovers here
to end up on the right.
Then we can go through all
these variables in reverse order
and then come back up here.
So that will be one non-crossing
path in this planar embedding.
Therefore, we've
constructed a new formula
where the bipartite graph
plus the path through all
the variables is planar.
And so this new version
of planar 3SAT is hard.
This version is usually
called planar 3SAT, but if you
want to distinguish
it, you could
call it planar 3SAT with a
variable cycle or something.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why is it
that we care about this?
PROFESSOR: Why do you care?
Aha.
We'll get to that
a little bit later.
Well, we've seen a lot
of proofs, actually,
where you visit a variable
and make a choice,
and then visit the next variable
and make a choice, and so on.
And when you make a choice, you
go visit the clauses and things
like that.
So when we're reducing
from planar 3SAT,
it's often handy to have
this traversable path.
If we have a robot or
somebody moving around,
then we can guarantee
planarity of that motion still.
And the connections
between the variables
don't have to cross anything.
In general, our goal here is
to avoid crossover gadgets
when we're reducing from
3SAT to something else.
So this gives you kind
of a generic crossover,
so that as long as you can
do variables and clauses more
or less independently and
you can build connections,
then you don't have to worry
about the connections crossing.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you're
given this bipartite graph,
how do you actually tell whether
an edge is negated or not?
PROFESSOR: You're still
given a formula, let's say.
And then you're just
told this extra fact
that the bipartite graph plus
this path and the variables,
in that order, is planar.
AUDIENCE: The
variable nodes, you
have one for every variable
and its first negation?
Or do you just--
PROFESSOR: No.
Sorry.
There's only vertices for
variables and for clauses,
not for literals.
But the next version is
actually about that case.
The next one is-- so the
idea, if you were just
given the bipartite
graph, you'd have
to be told the coloring
of the edges here
to know which literal
you're talking about.
But also, the problem
remains planar
if we use literals
instead of variables.
So if you were wondering
about that version,
that will also be planar.
It doesn't follow immediately.
But the idea is
suppose we have vi.
So in the regular
bipartite graph,
we have some positive edges and
we have some negative edges.
Instead, I want to represent
that as vi and vi bar.
And the positive
connections are over here.
The negative connections
are over here.
Now I don't need
the two coloring,
because I have the labels
to tell me which is which.
And furthermore, I can add
this edge connecting them.
That will still be planar.
So just split vi into two parts.
What this tells me is that
the positive connections to vi
appear as a contiguous chunk.
And the negative connections
So it's not like alternating
white, red, white, red.
So far, it is if you
look at the reduction.
But we can fix that.
OK.
So I just want to add, with an
edge between the xi and xi bar.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you say you
add an edge between them,
what does that mean?
Because all the
edges are supposed
to be in between
literals and clauses.
PROFESSOR: Well, I mean, the
graph already wasn't bipartite.
We start with a bipartite graph
between variables and literals.
Then we also add the
edges between variables
and their complements.
And then we also add a cycle
among all the variables,
among all the
literals, let's say.
So I guess this could be part
of the cycle, for example.
And that graph, which is not
bipartite, must be planar.
That's the constraint.
The claim is that all
such problems are NP-hard.
In general, we want to
make as small a problem
as we can, as special a
case as we can NP-hard,
because then we're reducing.
We have more structure
that we get to exploit.
This is a special case of this
is a special case of this.
So the more we can
confine it, the better.
Cool.
So this is proved also in
the Lichtenstein paper.
Although, we'll see a
cleaner proof in a moment,
so I won't cover this
in too much detail.
But the idea is this.
So we're taking
each variable, we're
replacing it with a
big cycle like this.
I think it's the same kind
of trick as over here.
It doesn't matter.
All these a's should be the
same or sort of alternating.
And we're connecting
the negative side--
so this is really two
vertices connected by an edge.
But I draw it like
that to make clear
that that represents the same
variable to literals of it.
And do this thing.
And then this is the path.
So suppose the path used
to go through this way.
Then the path now bisects.
And you see that all
of the positive copies
are on one side, and negative
copies are on the other side.
That's the idea.
We will see another proof
of a stronger statement,
so I think let's
not worry about this
too much unless
there are questions.
Here's the stronger statement.
So in general, the
variable cycle--
so I'm going to not subdivide
into literals for the moment.
But we could put that back.
So here's the variable cycle.
This decomposes the
plane at two regions--
the interior and the exterior.
Or course, I could
flip the edge,
and it doesn't matter which
one's interior and exterior.
But there are two regions.
And what I'm going to
require is that every clause
that I draw here should have
entirely positive connections
on this side.
And every clause
that I draw out here
should have entirely
negative connections.
OK?
This is monotone 3SAT again.
So this implies monotone.
We know monotone 3SAT is hard.
Now we're claiming that
planar monotone 3SAT
is hard when all the
positive clauses are
on one side of the
variable cycle,
and all the negative clauses
are on the other side.
This is really helpful.
I haven't yet given
this problem a name,
because it has a name that
uses another word, which
I should first introduce.
So that's the next page.
That word is
"rectilinear." so this
is a relatively simple
modification to what we
have already.
I want the variables
to live on the x-axis.
You can think of them
as horizontal segments
on the x-axis.
I prefer this drawing.
So imagine each variable is like
a little horizontal segment,
or in this case, a box.
And the clauses are
horizontal segments.
And then they're connected
by vertical segments
between the clause
and the variable.
And all of the clauses
that are above the x-axis
should be all positive.
All the clauses that
are below the x-axis
should be all negative.
That would be planar
monotone rectilinear 3SAT,
and I jumped the gun.
Planar rectilinear has
no such constraint.
Each of these could be
positive or negative.
OK.
So variables are segments.
All right.
So each variable is a
segment on the x-axis.
And each clause is another
horizontal segment,
plus vertical connections
to the three variables
that it includes in
positive or negative form.
OK.
And then planar monotone
rectilinear 3SAT
is a special case
of monotone 3SAT,
where all positive
clauses are above the line
and conversely, above x-axis.
Every clause above the x-axis
should be all positive.
And every clause below the
x-axis should be all negative.
OK.
So I guess this one you
could call monotone planar
3SAT without rectilinear.
But of course, rectilinear
doesn't change much.
I didn't say why, but if
you have a planar drawing
like we had before, this is
just a particularly nice way
to make that drawing.
To go here, I just used the fact
that there are no crossings.
And I stretched out the
variables to decent lengths,
so that clauses can
just go straight down.
You can prove any planar graph
can be drawn in this way.
Any planar graph that has the
vi cycle and has some degree--
three vertices that
connect to variables.
They have to nest in
this way, because if you
think of a clause,
they could either
be in this pocket or outside
of it, or down in this region.
And so you can just
figure out how big
this thing needs to be, and then
make the next one a little bit
bigger.
And so you can
represent the nesting
in this nice orthogonal,
or rectilinear structure.
Rectilinear just means
horizontal and vertical lines.
Cool?
So that's planar rectilinear
3SAT first observed
by Knuth and Raghunathan.
Now we want to-- let's
prove that planar monotone
rectilinear 3SAT is also hard.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
If rectilinearity just is a
nice way to draw the graph,
can we use the fact that it's
rectilinear in our reductions?
I mean, is that going
to help us any more?
PROFESSOR: The rectilinear
helps us mainly
when we're reducing to a
problem that lives on a grid.
It's just a convenient
way of thinking about it.
It doesn't directly help us.
I mean, it's a linear
time reduction.
I mean, all of these
are reductions,
so of course, none of
them help us in theory.
But the cleaner you can
make the problem-- I mean,
this looks pretty.
And we'll see, I
think at the end
of class, a proof that
directly mimics this structure.
So that's the only reason.
You could, of course,
as a first step, say,
hey, draw it rectilinearly.
But this saves you that step.
Cool.
All right.
So planar monotone
rectilinear 3SAT.
Here's an explicit example.
Although it's not
going to be modified,
it's just another example
of planar rectilinear 3SAT
without the monotone.
You see there's negations
above, lack of negations below.
And here is the
trick to fix things.
So suppose you have a
variable xi on the x-axis,
you have a clause above
it that uses that variable
in the wrong orientation.
So of course, or the
reflective picture.
But let's say it's above.
It's U is negated.
So in general, we have a
bunch of connections up.
We have a bunch of
connections down.
This one is somewhere
in the middle.
These bold lines are
just to distinguish
these are the ones to the right,
these are the ones to the left.
They don't mean
negation, necessarily.
Because this one
should be negated.
OK.
So we're just going to
replace it like this.
This is the trick that we
saw in the right and bottom
corner of the crossover gadget.
We're going to duplicate
xi, way except we'll
negate it at the same time.
So the other one had a negation
here and one negation here,
not here.
This xi or a, together with
xi bar or a bar-- again,
these are 2SAT clauses.
You have to duplicate
an edge to make it 3SAT.
That forces xi to
be not a, I think.
Maybe I even have
that as a fate.
OK, xi is not equal to a.
Similarly, a does not equal
b, which means b equals xi.
OK?
So we just duplicated xi to be
used in all the old scenarios.
And maybe these guys
still all go down.
We could move some of them
over here if we wanted to.
The ones to the left
have to be over here.
The ones to the right
This one gets to use
a negated copy of xi.
So boom, one negation down.
One negation that was
on the wrong side.
Repeat this n times.
Where you have a negation
you're not supposed to
and everywhere you don't
have a negation that you're
supposed to, apply this trick.
You'll increase the
number of variables
by some constant factor.
And now you're in
the monotone case.
So that's actually really easy.
It's our first proof that
monotone 3SAT is hard.
But it's a pretty easy one.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can we use
a similar construction
to recover splitting the
variables into literals?
PROFESSOR: Oh, to do this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Because we dropped that when
we moved over here, right?
AUDIENCE: But you said
it was just [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, we sort of did.
No, actually, this is supposed
to be a generalization of this,
because you could just
split apart-- I mean, you
can carve vi in half
to the positive side
and the negative side.
And all the negative
sides are below,
and all the positive
sides are above.
So yeah, we could
already do that.
Right.
Because this was not
about having them--
it was about having the vertices
labeled as literals instead of
as variables.
So we don't need to explicitly
say that this one does not
equal that one.
That's already in the problem.
So we can combine all of
the things I've said so far.
That may not always be the case,
but so far, we can combine all.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Silly question.
If we're carving them into
positive side of the variable
on one side and negative
on the other side,
wouldn't that make
all the connections
below that positive
connections instead
of negative connections?
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
I don't mean split it in
the way of that diagram.
I mean that we
could, in this sense,
we could have vertices
represent a positive vi
and a negative vi, and
have the connections.
This was saying that
we could separate
the positive connections
from the negative ones.
And I'm just saying we
already have that here.
This is a stronger property
to say that they're also
all in the same direction.
If you just had this
property, then you
could have some white
here and some white here,
and red here and red here.
But this is saying you
can get them all aligned
in the right direction.
Yeah.
In fact, if we look
at this diagram,
maybe you didn't
understand this diagram,
but it has the same issue.
Or this is exactly
that kind of picture.
So here we have a5.
The positive is over here,
the negative is over here.
Here we have a4.
The negative is there,
and the positive is there.
So this was getting
the weaker property.
Again, you don't have
to worry about it,
because we got the stronger one.
But that's just to
show that there's
a difference between the two.
Good.
So that was planar
monotone rectilinear 3SAT.
OK.
I have a governor
general's warning.
So here's another problem.
Suppose we have
the variable cycle.
And I say, well, every
clause is inside the cycle.
And you are free to have
positive and negative
connections.
It's going to get hard.
OK.
Something like that.
And it's planar.
That problem is
polynomially solvable.
So I'll rephrase this.
If all the clauses are on one
side, of the variable cycle,
then that version of 3SAT
is polynomially solvable.
And the intuition is that
this kind of nesting structure
is essentially a tree.
If you look at what
nests inside of what,
what clauses fall
underneath other clauses,
that is a nesting relation,
which corresponds to a tree.
And then you just do dynamic
programming over the tree.
That's easy.
The sort of surprising
thing is that just
having two of these trees, one
on the inside of the cycle, one
on the outside, is enough
to make the problem hard.
That's a typical
thing, actually,
because the trees interdigitate.
They have no real
relation to each other,
and there's no way to
keep track of both of them
simultaneously with the dynamic
program unless P equals mp.
OK.
So that's one gotcha
to be careful of.
So when you're doing
your reductions,
you have to worry about things
above the line and things
below the line.
Also, here's a
special case of this.
Suppose I phrase the
following problem.
I want the bipartite graph
on variables versus clauses,
plus the cycle v1
through vn back to v1,
plus another cycle on the
clause's c1 to cn and back
to c1.
I want that whole
graph to be planar.
OK?
If you think about
that for a second, that
would imply all the
clauses are on one side
of the variable cycle.
And so we're in this
case, which is easy.
So this is a special
case of that case.
Now, this one I mentioned,
because if this were hard,
life would be so easy.
It's not so life isn't easy.
But you already knew that.
Recall, say, proving
push-1 is hard in 2D.
Well, first we did it in 3D and
then we had a crossover gadget.
And most of the work was
in the crossover gadget.
The base proof was
trivial or very easy.
So we can get all of these
connections between variables
and clauses to be planar.
We can get all of these
connections, the variables
in a line, to be
planar together,
all of those things together.
But we cannot also have a path
connecting all the clauses
together.
Even a path.
So I said a path here,
which is what we want.
So that's annoying,
because if we
could make all of
these things planar,
we wouldn't have to worry
about these crossovers.
Same thing with all the Nintendo
proofs, like Super Mario
Brothers again.
The player is going from
one variable to the next,
so you need those edges
connecting all the variables
in a path.
You need the edges
connecting the clauses
in a path for the final check.
So planar 3SAT
basically doesn't buy
you anything in these proofs.
Now, if we could somehow avoid
adding these connections,
everything else could be planar.
That's sort of the
point of planar 3SAT.
So if you can avoid
these things--
and there are a lot of games
where that would happen.
Just you have to
get a point here,
and it's just added
to your total score
in some Never Never
Land not in the plane,
then life would be much easier,
because you wouldn't need
a crossover gadget,
because you can just
reduce from planar 3SAT.
OK?
That should give
you some intuition
why we care about
planar 3SAT, but also
why we didn't use it
for those problems.
As far as we know,
there's no way
to use planar 3SAT and make a
simpler Super Mario Brothers
proof or whatever.
OK.
So next topic.
We will see some
planar 3SAT proofs,
reductions from planar 3SAT.
But let me first tell you
about other versions of 3SAT.
Remember there are three
main versions-- planar 3SAT,
planar 1-in-3SAT, and-- sorry.
There are three versions
of 3SAT-- 3SAT, 1-in-3SAT,
and Not All Equal SAT.
Turns out 1-in-3SAT is hard
when its graphs are planar.
Not All Equal SAT is easy
when graphs are planar.
So I will show you both.
AUDIENCE: For this
easy case, do you
have to have both the
variables in the cycle
and a clauses in a cycle?
Or is it just like seeing the
clauses in a path or cycle
immediately triggers
this easy condition?
PROFESSOR: So I don't know.
I think if the
clauses are in a path
and the variables are
not connected at all,
it should still be hard.
But I couldn't find
a proof of that.
It's just a vague recollection.
So I'm pretty sure if
variables are in a path
and clauses are in a path,
then that's enough to be toast.
But all I proved here was cycle.
But I think a path is enough.
It will still
behave like a tree.
Mm.
Maybe not.
I'm not sure.
Yeah.
So it's a good question.
All right.
Let's do planar 1-in-3SAT.
So it's pretty much
the same thing.
I won't duplicate
all of the text here.
We take the bipartite graph
of variables versus clauses.
And we also add
a path, or cycle,
connecting all the variables.
And that graph should be planar.
And otherwise, it's
1-in-3SAT, exactly 1-in-3SAT.
So here's the proof.
It's one of the easiest
proofs we'll cover.
Suppose you have a clause.
It's a reduction from planar
3SAT to planar 1-in-3SAT.
OK?
So this is also our first
proof of 1-in-3SAT being hard.
We are going to take
a regular 3SAT clause
and turn it into three
1-in-3SAT clauses.
And that transformation
preserves planarity, so done.
So all of our proofs
are going to just keep
building up in this way.
We've already proved
this problem's hard
when the graph is planar.
So let's do this.
At least one of
them should be 1.
We don't want them all to be 0.
So let's try when they're all 0,
see if something should break.
Let's say this variable
is 0, easier to reach.
So that makes this
guy satisfied,
which means both of
these must be false.
This variable's
just hanging out.
It's just to make
everything degree three.
So if this is 0, this
is 1, so this must be 0.
So this is 0.
This is 0.
That means exactly one
of these should be 1.
If cp is 1, obviously,
we're happy.
But this will end up
forcing this guy to be 0.
Or sorry.
Actually, it'll leave this
guy free to do whatever.
So if this is 0, 0, 0,
then this must be 1.
This is 1.
Therefore, both of these are 0.
If zr bar is 0, that
must mean this one is 1.
So if both of these were 0,
it forced this guy to be a 1.
If this was 0 and this is
1, for example, this is 1.
Then this must be 0/ OK.
This is 0.
But we're free to set
either one of these to 1.
So zr is free, which
is what we want to do.
We're simulating regular 3SAT.
If this is 1, then
both of these guys
should be able to do
whatever they want.
And that's what these
guys let you do.
They're free floating.
This guy can toggle if
it's not constrained
to be the only guy that's 1.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's the
dashed line represent?
PROFESSOR: Dashed line is
the outline of the gadget.
It's just saying you replace
that blob with this blob.
I mean, slightly
more formally, I
think it's saying
something like,
if you contract this to a
point or if you contract this
to a point, then it's
exactly the same diagram.
So it's one way to
argue you preserve
planarity, something like that.
So ignore it, basically.
Now, I guess you
would have to argue
that you can still have a path
that visits all the variables.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
What's preventing you from
setting all three to false?
PROFESSOR: That is one
of the cases I just did.
If these two are false,
then these have to be true.
No, sorry.
These have to be 0.
So these are both 0.
And then this has to
be a 1 or satisfy this.
It's easy to get confused,
because that one is 3SAT,
this one is 1-in-3SAT.
So these all have
exactly 1 constraints.
OK.
Now, this proof has negations.
And you may recall
that monotone--
I'm going to switch to saying
positive 1-in-3SAT where you
have no negations is also hard.
So we can also define
planar positive 1-in-3SAT.
This is also hard by a slightly
more complicated proof,
more recent proof also.
Surprisingly, this planar
monotone rectilinear 3SAT,
or just planar monotone
3SAT, is also very recent.
I think 2010.
So a lot of these
just fell recently
but are a natural culmination
of all these simplifications.
So this is a version
that-- well, these
are some gadgets, actually.
This is one way to force
the two variables to have
opposite values and force
equal values, using--
I guess this is really
planar positive
rectilinear 1-in-3SAT.
It's the 1-in-3SAT
version of this problem.
So again, variables
are on the x-axis.
Everything above is
implicitly all positive.
Everything below is
implicitly all negative.
Oh, sorry.
Here, everything
is all positive.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Another
nice thing to note
about that particular
construction
is that each of the variables
in the clauses are unique,
so it's exactly 3.
And they're all
unique, which someone
was asking about before.
PROFESSOR: Good.
So in this construction,
1-in-3SAT, all of the clauses
do not repeat any variables.
Exactly three
distinct guys, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So to be clear,
this problem is hard,
but in this terminology, planar
positive rectilinear 3SAT,
not 1-in-3SAT, is easy.
Because if everything was
on one side of the line--
PROFESSOR: I mean,
positive 3SAT is easy.
You set all the
variables to true.
AUDIENCE: I'm confused.
Positive means that--
PROFESSOR: Positive is sort
of the 1-in-3SAT version
of monotone.
So 3SAT monotone
means every clause is
all positive or all negative.
In 1-in-3SAT, you just
need everything positive.
And it's still hard.
But with 3SAT, that
doesn't work, because you
can set everything to true.
1-in-3SAT requires
some false things.
So it's sort of the analog.
This is sometimes called planar
monotone rectilinear 1-in-3SAT.
But to avoid confusion, because
they are somewhat different,
I'm calling it positive.
I think this paper
actually calls it positive,
which makes me happy.
Anyway, you can check these
gadgets that they force.
In particular here, you're
basically forcing a to b 0
by this little construction.
You can see as 1.
Therefore, this clause
forces exactly one of these
to be true, the
other to be false.
So it forces them
to be different.
You repeat that twice,
you get equality.
Then you do this.
First, you get rid
of all negations,
because you have
this way to force
two things to be different.
These Xed out ones
are the red lines.
Those are connected
to negated copies.
You just duplicate the
variable in negated form
and then use a wire there.
So this wire
becomes that one. x2
is different from x1.
x3 is different from x2.
So it's equal to x1.
Same trick we saw before.
Now you have no negations.
So now this type of
clause is a 3SAT clause.
It's a little weird.
Right of the arrows, these
are 1-in-3SAT clauses.
Left of the arrows are
regular 3SAT clauses.
So we replace this
with this construction.
It's sort of like the
old one but a little bit
spread out, with
the duplications,
with these equal gadgets.
We get a copy of x over here.
That's so that if we have
more connections below,
we can easily access x still.
And yeah.
These 1-in-3 gadgets
constrain this.
Yeah, there is an equal gadget--
AUDIENCE: The equals
and not equals
are not part of the
problem, they're
just referring to
the earlier gadget.
PROFESSOR: No.
Right.
That's shorthand
for these gadgets.
So you would plug in
each of those things
into those little pictures.
Yeah.
OK.
So let's skip those details.
But you get that planar positive
rectilinear 1-in-3SAT is hard.
And that was 2008.
Cool.
Let's do planar
Not All Equal 3SAT.
This is polynomial.
Important thing to remember--
in the planar world,
you have to be careful
with all sorts of things.
It would be nice to have
a Schaefer-type dichotomy
theorem for planar graphs, but I
don't know of any such theorem.
So meanwhile, this is the
sort of main characterization.
You have those three
standard problems.
This one falls in
the planar case.
Same setup.
We have Not All Equal
clauses and the connections
between those and the
variables negated or not.
Even when you allow negations,
this problem is polynomial.
The fun thing is the proof of
this theorem is a reduction,
and it looks exactly
like a hardness proof.
I mean-- [LAUGHS]
It just happens
to be from this problem to a
known polynomial time problem,
namely, planar max cut.
So we're going to
reduce to-- this
is one of the few times we will
reduce to something-- planar
max cut.
So max cut is I
give you a graph,
and I want to color the
vertices two different colors.
Think of them as the
two sides of a cut.
Say red and blue.
And I want to
maximize the number
of edges that are red, blue.
So I want to maximize the number
of, here, white-black edges,
bichromatic edges.
That's max cut.
In general graphs, that's
NP-hard, but in planar graphs,
it's easy, because if you
look at the dual graph
and then solve the Chinese
postman tour problem, which
is the shortest path that
visits all of the edges at least
once, which you can
do in polynomial time
by perfect matching and a
bipartite null in a cleek.
Anyway, you do that.
And then all the edges that
you double are not in the cut,
I think.
And all the edges that you
don't double in that tour
are in the max cut.
Fun fact.
So this is a known fact.
Planar max cut is easy.
So if we reduce from planar
Not Equal 3SAT to max cut,
the problem is easy.
And here's the proof.
It's got a variable gadget and
a Not All Equal clause gadget.
So we want to represent
Not All Equal.
And so the idea is we're
going to represent a variable
with this alternating chain.
And if you want to maximize
the number of red-blue edges,
you should alternate, because
this have even length.
If you don't alternate
anywhere, you're
going to not get as many edges.
In general, we'll say,
well, the target cut
size you're trying to
get, the decision problem
is, is there a cut of
size at least something?
The something is going to
be, in particular, it's
going to be a sum of
things, but for this gadget,
it is two times the
number of occurrences
that the variable would
say, or basically the length
of this cycle.
We'll just make the
cycle big enough,
so we get lots of copies of
xi, lots of copies of xi bar.
So this is one possible setting.
If blue means true, this is like
saying that we set xi to true.
We could do the reverse.
We could set xi to false
and set xi bar to true.
But they have to be opposites.
So now we have-- this is
basically a split gadget.
We have several copies
of xi and xi bar.
Then we're going to connect them
with this Not All Equal clause,
which is just a triangle.
And the idea is if these
are-- so this is really
a negated version of xi,
but it doesn't matter.
If you negate all the variables,
they'll still be not all equal.
And exactly when
they're not all equal,
we get two points
out of this gadget.
Well, we also have to
get the three points
from these connections.
That forces this alternation.
So we say the target
in this gadget
is to get a cut of size 5.
We want five red-blue edges.
That's the most you could hope
for because of an odd cycle
here.
And if you get the sum of all
these cut sizes, in total,
you must have Not All
Equal in every clause.
So that's simulating
Not All Equal-- planar
Not All Equal 3SAT.
This also preserves planarity.
And we just contract
the variable
to a point, the
clauses to a point.
And it is the bipartite graph
of the Not All Equal picture.
And we've simulated that planar
Not All Equal 3SAT instance
with planar max cut,
which here, we actually
have a polynomial algorithm.
So that gives us a
polynomial algorithm
for planar Not All Equal 3SAT.
So that's kind of fun.
Similar style.
Yeah.
Good.
So many problems.
So I guess now we're going
to do some reductions
from various planar 3SAT
things to problems you might
care a little bit more about.
I'm going to
start-- I mean, it's
sort of a vague
transition, because these,
you could think of just more
problems of the same type.
X3C is something we talked about
in the context of 3PARTITION.
This was exact cover
with sets of size 3.
I think Exact Cover
So this was-- you could
think of it as a hyper-graph.
Or you could think of
it as a bipartite graph.
You have sets of size 3
which cover variables.
You want every variable to
be covered exactly once.
But you can only
choose sets of size 3.
Yeah.
So this is closely related,
I guess, to planar 1-in-3SAT.
Here, each of these
things could have
arbitrary degree--
each element can
appear in many different sets.
Whereas over-- and you're
covering these with these.
I think this is the reverse
setup, where every-- let's see.
The clauses, again, have
to be exactly covered
by these things.
And these things
have arbitrary size.
So these are the things
that you're choosing.
I'm choosing to make
this variable true, which
covers this guy.
These have arbitrary size here.
The thing that I'm
choosing has size 3.
OK?
So it's sort of the dual of--
AUDIENCE: What are you choosing?
PROFESSOR: --of
planar 1-in-3SAT.
So the goal-- maybe I should
write down the problem again.
You're given three sets.
These are sets of size 3.
And you want to choose,
let's say, k of them.
Actually, it would be choose
n/3 of them that are disjoint.
And therefore, every
element-- they're n elements--
every element is covered exactly
once by exactly one 3SAT.
So it's, I think,
sort of complementary
to planar 1-in-3SAT.
The planar version is that
this bipartite graph is planar.
And Dyer and Freeze,
this is same people
that approved one of these
many problems is hard.
I think the-- I'll look back.
Planar 1-in-3SAT.
So no surprise.
So we're going to reduce
from planar 1-in-3SAT
to this problem, prove
that this is hard.
And here's a very simple proof.
They make it more complicated.
But for starters,
let's make a variable
by this kind of
even cycle trick.
And the picture here is that
the big circles are 3SATs,
the dots are the elements
you're trying to cover.
And every element should
be covered exactly
by exactly one set.
So this looks good, because
there are exactly two ways
to solve this thing.
You could choose these guys
and cover those points exactly
once, in which case, this
is covered, this is covered,
and this is covered.
But these other
guys are uncovered.
Those are going to
attach to other gadgets.
Or you could do the reverse.
So that's going to correspond
to a true or false setting.
And I think-- this is
not in their paper,
but I think this would be a
clause for exactly one 3SAT.
Just connect-- you
could have even negated
versions of your variables.
But let's say we have all
positive planar 1-in-3SAT.
3, So I'll just
take a positive copy
of xi, a positive copy
of xj from somewhere,
and then just bring them
together at a common dot.
Then that point
should be covered
by exactly one of them, which
means exactly one of those
is true.
Done.
Very easy.
Now, they want to
prove more things,
so they end up using-- I think
I will just show you for fun.
They end up using a more
complicated clause and a more
complicated way to connect
these things into the clause,
because they want to prove
another problem hard,
which is planar
three-dimensional matching.
Three-dimensional matching
was a generalization
of numerical three-dimensional
matching, which was
closely related to 3PARTITION.
In general,
three-dimensional matching,
it's like this problem.
But you also have
the extra information
that for every set of size
3, one of these is red,
another one is blue,
another one is yellow.
This paper uses the
additive primary colors.
I don't know why.
It could be green if you prefer.
So there are three
types of elements.
And you're told that every
set has one of each type.
So that's extra information
that's useful in some proofs.
So this is a better
construction,
because it's going to end
up being three-colorable.
Yeah.
I don't know how much you
care about this reduction.
I think I will skip the
details, although I spent
a lot of time understanding it.
The rough idea is that
these connectors-- there's
a positive and a negative
version, because they're
worried about negations.
But these connections
will attach
to these three terminals
for one variable,
these three terminals
for another,
and these three for another.
And just by a counting
argument in here,
there is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9 of these guys.
And there are however many--
I guess I should really
be counting the black dots.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9, 11, 12 points here.
So the best you can do is
to choose three of the sets
inside that will cover
all of the black dots
except for three of them.
And so from that, you
get exactly one 1SAT.
Exactly one of these should be
covered from somewhere else.
That would correspond
to this situation
where you cover
these three points as
opposed to this situation,
where none of them get covered.
That's like these guys.
And then you can
always satisfy the rest
by adding three in there.
So that's roughly how
that clause works.
Then that picture
is three-colorable.
And this way, you can color
all the dots with three colors.
And it pretty much works.
The variable
alternates red, yellow.
So we always get blue
connections, which is good.
So we can attach to
anything, except that the way
that we attach is like this.
And these are three
colors which match here.
And in this case, these
three colors match here.
But you might want to
attach here, for example.
So you need another connector,
which is slightly different.
This does exactly
the same thing,
but now this color
pattern matches
here, but in negated form.
And if you switch these two
colors, it matches here,
I think when it's upside-down.
So there's this version, and
there's the reflected version.
And then there's also this
coloring of the same gadget.
And so you do all these things.
You know what you're
supposed to connect,
and so you just choose one
of these three gadgets,
and it connects to one of
the three appropriate places.
That's their proof.
It was fun to read.
And that proves that planar
three-dimensional matching
is hard.
OK.
Plus, in their
diagrams, oh, they
have dashed lines through
everything in order
to illustrate that you
can have one path that
visits all of the elements,
just like in planar 3SAT.
So also, both planar
three-dimensional matching and
planar exact cover by 3SATs,
you can have one cycle
that visits every element.
Yeah.
Cool.
Here's another
relatively simple proof.
This is in the original
Lichtenstein paper,
so this is one of their
motivations for planar 3SAT.
Planar vertex cover.
So what's vertex cover?
You're given a graph.
You want to choose
a set of vertices
that cover all of the edges.
So for example, if
you have a triangle,
and I choose this vertex,
it covers this edge,
and it covers this edge.
I have one edge uncovered.
So I'm going to add
this one and cover that.
So I don't require
exactly one cover.
Just every edge has to be
covered by at least one
of its endpoints.
So you can think of it as
an oar of its two endpoints.
OK.
But this problem is NP-hard
even for planar graphs.
And here's one way to do.
This is like the whole
proof in one little picture.
You have a variable
gadget, which,
again, is just a even cycle.
And in an even cycle,
the vertex cover--
let's say this has size k.
And I give you the budget of
only k/2 for your vertex cover,
then you have to alternate.
So either these three guys
are in your vertex cover,
or these three guys are.
This proof actually
looks the same
as the last one we saw, right?
Then those things are just
connected to triangles.
Same deal here.
I'm going to give
you a budget of two
for this clause, because to
cover all three of these edges,
you need at least two vertices,
like we did over there.
And if you're going to get
away with only two-- so
if I choose, for
example, these two, that
also covers this edge
and this edge for free.
But it does not cover this edge.
This would be the one edge
not covered by the clause
alone if you only
get a budget of two.
And that's the
one that better be
covered by this
side, which means
this variable is set to true.
And in general, at least
one of these three things
better be covered.
Otherwise you won't
have enough budget
to finish that triangle clause.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So the hexagon
versus square here
is just to give you
more connection points
into other clauses?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Just make these
cycles big enough
to connect up to all the
things you need it in.
So if you have ni
occurrences, you're
going to do, like,
2 ni or something.
Cool.
So that's planar vertex cover.
And because this reduction
preserved planarity,
we get planar
vertex cover's hard,
because planar 3SAT is hard.
Here we didn't need
any connections
between the variables.
Here's one where we
do need connections
between the variables.
So this is planar-directed
Hamiltonian cycle.
So I think you all know
what Hamiltonian cycle is.
And you're given a
directed graph here.
You want to find one path that
visits every vertex exactly
once.
Don't care about edges.
So we can do a
similar kind of thing.
The proof is a little bit--
but checking this works is
a little bit more annoying.
But here's Lichtenstein's
idea for variable.
Essentially, a wire.
The graph is directed here.
So we get to say there's
an incoming edge here.
Then you get a choice.
So which way it'll go.
But then you basically
have to alternate.
Because of these
vertices in the middle,
you've got to visit all of them.
And the only way to do
that is to alternate.
So you get this
alternating pattern,
which means if you look at
these edges, a1 and a1 bar,
exactly one of these is in.
And then the opposite
of these are in.
The variable here is called a.
So there's many instances of a.
And these are going to
be in-- they're going
to be both in or both out.
And then these are going to be
both out or both in and so on.
So because I have
to zigzag, I made
a bunch of copies, ni
copies of the variable a.
But you're free to choose
one setting or the other.
And then the clause is just
going to be a single vertex.
And the idea is if we want b
bar to satisfy this clause,
we're going to add
in those two edges.
So instead of going straight
here, you could have done this
and grabbed the clause for free.
You don't have to.
But this is going to
get grabbed if and only
if exactly-- at
least one of these
chooses the appropriate edge.
If you're using
this edge, there's
no way to cover this clause.
But if using this
edge, you can do that.
You have to check that you
can't let go from here to there
to over here.
That's what this
figure is about.
So basically, if you're
alternating here,
you switch sides, and then
you're alternating here,
this guy is uncovered.
And apparently, this
proof works even
when the graph is undirected,
but that's even less clear.
We'll see other
Hamiltonian cycle proofs
that are stronger than this.
But it's a nice illustration.
Here we're using that we
can connect all the vertices
together.
That's what these
connections are in the cycle.
So there's this big
vertex loop on the outside
taking these gadgets,
and pasting them together
in a big loop, because we want
an overall Hamiltonian cycle.
Because we know that preserves
linearity, life is good.
OK.
So there'll be some
clauses inside the cycle,
some clauses outside the cycle.
But that doesn't matter.
OK.
That's planar-directed
Hamiltonian cycle.
Time for a Nikoli game.
I bumped into this slide
that I made a while ago.
So for fun, these are
all the Nikoli games
I know that have been proved
hard except the one I'm
going to talk about.
These are the references.
We covered one of them,
right, the Light Up.
But there's a lot.
And lots of papers proving them.
So here's a relatively new game.
It came out a couple
years ago in Nikoli land,
although it was
invented before that.
Shakashaka, which is
like a shaking sound.
So we have a square grid, blank
squares, and obstacle squares.
The obstacle squares, some of
them have numbers, some of them
are wild cards.
And what you're allowed to do
for a blank square-- or some
of the blank squares,
you can fill in one half.
So you have like
four different halves
of the square you can choose.
There they are-- this one, this
one, this one, and this one.
And you can fill it in
half black, half white.
So you cut along a
diagonal, and then you
choose one of the two
halves to fill in black.
You don't have to.
You could just leave it white.
And when you have
a numbered square,
then the number of filled things
must be exactly that number.
So here, there's one adjacent
to it, and nothing down here.
This guy has exactly two
half-filled squares next to it.
This one has exactly one.
This one has exactly
zero half-filled squares.
Think of blank squares as zeros
and these as counting as one.
Plus, the goal is that the
regions you make-- this
would all be easy
so far, I think.
But the extra constraint is
that all the regions you make
must be rectangles.
OK?
This is a 45-degree-rotated
rectangle.
This is a regular rectangle.
So you can use either one.
So it's a funny constraint.
It's actually quite
a fun game to play.
You're not allowed to
fill in a square 100%.
That one was already filled.
That's the rules.
Here's a reduction
from planar 3SAT.
Pretty simple.
Looks a lot like
Minesweeper, in some sense,
a little bit thickened.
But this is a
wire, because the 1
says that one of the two
sides is half-filled.
Once that's half-filled, you
have to make this a rectangle.
You can't just leave
it as a pentagon.
So you've got to fill that
in to a rotated square.
But because of the 1, this
must be an empty square.
So it alternates.
You can do this or this.
OK.
You can easily split just
by connecting those things
in the obvious way.
You can do 90-degree turns.
No problem.
Here's a slightly more
sophisticated-- slightly more
sophisticated gadget.
You can think of
this as a terminator.
It would be hard to just
stop this somewhere.
Well, maybe you could
just go all black.
I think that's OK as well.
This could also be a terminator.
You can also think
of this as a negator.
Of course, also, the
splitter's like a negator.
This guide's just
probably not so necessary.
Let's get to Clause.
So Clause is bringing
three things together
with one of these blocks.
But we do it in a funny way.
There's no 1's here or here.
So we end up with
this L blank shape.
Everything else is
now drawn as black.
That's just obstacles.
So this is not
happy the way it is.
There's lots of
ways to resolve it.
The one case where
we can't resolve
it is when all of these wires
are 0's, because there's
already stuff here, and
stuff here, and stuff here,
so we can't put anything here.
Can't put anything
here, or here, or here,
because of those 1's.
Then you're forced to have
the L shape, and you're toast.
In every other case,
we can decompose
into sometimes a big rectangle,
sometimes little squares,
sometimes rotated squares.
But that's OK.
So this is a
regular 3SAT clause.
The one thing that's
missing at this point
is a parity shift gadget,
because a lot of these gadgets
have very specific lengths,
modular 3 or whatever.
So it turns out this is a
way to shift things slightly.
It can be filled in two ways.
You can fill in all of
these guys like that
and make this giant
rotated square.
Or if these are not allowed
because these are here,
then you can do
this weird filling.
You end up with a rectangle
there, and two rotated squares,
another rectangle.
And you count the total length.
This is length 4, whereas most
of the things are length 2?
AUDIENCE: 3 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: 3.
OK.
So that makes me happy.
Shift the parity.
And that is Shakashaka.
Here's an overall
picture where we actually
plugged some gadgets together.
That was fun.
So I think I have one
more proof to just sketch.
So this is a problem of
so-called fixed-angle chains.
So you have this
forced 90-degree angle.
We had a similar thing
with the Hamiltonian path
with cubes and
elastics between them.
You could twist one
edge around the other,
one block around the other, but
you couldn't adjust this angle.
OK?
So the problem is I give
you such a chain, which
is specified by lengths
and then 90-degree angles.
So it can be-- you don't know
whether the 90-degree angle
goes up or down.
And you want to just put it into
the plane without crossings.
And this is an old
proof from 2000.
The problem is weakly NP-hard.
It's basically a
partition proof,
so it is a partition proof.
You get to choose, for
each of these things,
whether it goes left or right.
And you need to line
up this with that.
Otherwise you get collisions.
You would just need to argue.
This outer structure has a
unique embedding, roughly.
Unique enough.
It always looks like that.
So we proved a few years ago
that it is strongly NP-hard.
And I will just
sketch the proof,
because it's fun and cool.
So here's the rough idea.
Imagine this is like
a piece of wire.
And you can flip it up or down.
All the angles stay 90 degrees.
These are the down-case.
Here are some example up-cases.
One of them's going to
represent false, the other true.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What's the difference
between this and the Carpenter
Ruler problem?
PROFESSOR: Which Carpenter?
AUDIENCE: Like you have
to fold the ruler to fit.
PROFESSOR: Oh, to fit
inside a given length.
Well, the goal is different.
Here, the goal is to draw it
in the plane without crossings.
Before, the goal was to draw it
in the plane with minimum span.
To fit inside box.
Yeah.
I mean, this proof is
pretty much the same.
This proof will be
totally different.
That problem was also
only weakly hard.
There was a pseudo
poly-algorithm.
This problem is
strongly NP-hard.
There is no pseudo
poly-algorithm
unless P equals np.
So just a slightly
different goal.
That one was more
one-dimensional.
This is going to be much
more two-dimensional That's
the other difference.
OK.
So this is our some
kind of variable gadget.
This is the variables gadget.
All n variables are
represented here.
This represents one variable.
At this point, I only have
one copy of each variable,
because there's no
constraint between these.
Each of them can
independently flip up or down.
Next, we have a clause.
This is where things get fun.
So there's some infrastructure,
but the main action is here.
Each of these is
sort of independently
pop in or outable.
It's like some kind
of pleated form.
It can either pleat back and
forth, like it's doing here,
where it pleats in and
out and out and in.
And that gets this
to this position.
With a slightly
different pleating,
it ends up in this position.
Or a slightly
different pleating,
where they're all out, you
end up in this position.
And notice this structure.
So I'll go through it again.
Here's the left one.
And then the middle one.
And then the last one.
What ends up happening is
that these pegs, in order
to avoid hitting that peg, I
occupy either P1 or P2 or P3.
So I'll go through
it one more time.
Here it's hitting P1,
because this basically
pushes this thing down.
Whereas the other
ones can be up-- this
is up and up and up and up.
Or if we shift it
into the middle,
then this one has to be down.
But this guy can be up
and avoid P1 but hit P2.
Or this one's down, these
are up, and we hit P3.
We want to avoid
collisions, so we
have to collide with
exactly one of these things,
or at least one
of them, I guess.
So that's the sort of picture.
This is a bunch
of those clauses.
There's one here, there's one
here, and there's one here.
Look familiar?
This is planar monotone
rectilinear 3SAT, I think.
So far so good,
except this chain
is separate from
this one, so we're
going to connect them together.
Is a little more, I think.
Yeah.
Connect them together.
So now it is one big chain.
What I ended up doing,
there's still this big thing
to represent the
entire variable.
But I basically made a
whole bunch of copies of it,
so that I could
attach things here.
But for example, when this
is up, all of these guys
have to simultaneously be up.
So it forces all the
copies of the variable
here to be one way or the other.
This is one variable,
this is another variable,
and this is another variable,
just like before.
So same thing, but now I can
connect them all together.
Up here, these are all the
negative, I think, clauses.
Doesn't matter.
And then down here, you put
all the positive clauses.
And that's the proof.
Question.
AUDIENCE: --all those
three dots in a row?
Like, it seems to me that if
you have two dots [INAUDIBLE]
straight line, they might as
well just merge into one dot.
PROFESSOR: I think the
idea is, yeah, this
could be a single line.
We subdivide it just to point
out that you can attach things
to it.
Yeah.
There's extra dots, but just
for consistency's sake, I guess.
So now everywhere here, you
can attach one of the clauses.
And that way, they
all kind of hold
to the same infrastructure.
Yeah.
Clear?
[LAUGHS]
So obviously, you get
pretty complicated pictures
in the end.
But this is a proof
that clearly benefited
from the rectilinear aspect
and the monotone aspect
that all the true thing-- we
could not get some true above
and some true below.
They all wanted to
go the same way.
And the rectilinear
was nice, so we
could draw this all
on a horizontal line
and only have to worry
about vertical connections
between the top and the bottom.
So that gets to
your question about,
why do we need rectilinear?
But there you go.
So that was just a few
examples of planar 3SAT.
But in general, the idea
is that a lot of 3SAT--
or many 3SAT proofs
get easier when you use
the appropriate planar version.
You just have to be careful
of ones that are not hard.
As long as you
avoid that and you
have the right sort
of graph setup,
you don't have to add
too many extra edges.
Then you'll have
planarity and not
have to worry about crossovers.
And crossover, it
wouldn't have a clue
how to do a crossover
in a problem like this.
And other times, it just makes
your life a little bit easier,
because you skip one gadget.
But that is planar 3SAT.